on to some happy news now having a
beautiful dress or a classy tux for the
prom is a dream for most high school
students and project 150's las vegas
prom closet helps make that dream come
true for hundreds of valley high school
kids for free bianca holmen is live to
tell us more about the prom closet
bianca this has got to be so exciting
for high school kids
this is a huge event prom is a big time
and a big event for so many high school
students so you know if they don't have
to pay for a dress and a tux i mean
parents they that is such a huge relief
for a lot of families that are
struggling let's look at all of these
rows of dresses down here we got the
accessories and joining us we've got
cenia roybal so tell us more about
project 150 and this prom closet for
those that don't know yeah so project
150 focuses on servicing
high school students with food hygiene
clothing and school supplies all for
free for this specific event again for
free we are providing formal wear for
students who might be attending prom or
any type of formal event and we're just
so lucky to have the community support
by donating all of these dresses and
suits as well as the accessories the
cost can really add up so tell me about
this year's event and it's sold out it's
coming up soon yes all completely sold
out however for any student that might
have not been able to register please
follow us on social media um we have an
upcoming pop-up event um this later on
this month all right and as i know it's
a sigh of relief you know you get the
parents here they get to see their
student dress up and in these amazing
gowns and the tuxes and so it really
makes a huge difference it boosts their
confidence oh definitely i mean we were
able to see the girls and their dresses
and is this okay is this okay and it
looks amazing on them and as well as the
young boys so um we are just so grateful
to be able to provide this service all
for free to be able to be a part of
their special event yeah well wonderful
again making a huge difference a lot of
our kids have missed this event so it's
great that it's back and it's going to
be here at their warehouse coming up
this weekend so more details about
project 150 all that they have going on
and again if you weren't able to come
out to this
year's event they got some other things
coming up we'll tell you about in the
next half hour i'm going to send it back
to you guys in the studio just a little
step for normalcy